once Jennifer Goldson got you this
script to read how much time passed
before you finally read it and then
finally said okay to it that's a
wonderful question because I don't think
that Bethany Jo Gamache is one of my
other producers and we'll even could
have believed that I believe we bought
the property in like October and we were
in pre-production in January and we shot
the movie and August or September or
something it's just unheard of but you
know that's the way I work and the
outcome of it is at this rate we can
produce a movie every couple years and
in success use the the moderate success
of these movies to finance the next
movie are you okay with talking about
what the next steps were once you all
agreed that we really loved this film
and we think we can do it for a
reasonable budget what were some of the
next things you did to actually secure
the deal well once we made a deal with
the screenwriter you you basically
option the script and you pay a certain
amount of money and thus that gives you
the comfort of writing the script
modifying the script and then actually
making the decision to greenlight it
that happened in just a few months for
me on this movie versus buying a script
off the shelf spending two years in
pre-production and then actually going
out and shooting it there's so many
there's so much equity in experience
here because first-timers including
myself you make a lot of mistakes and I
just mentioned one of them I mean we
just got a bill for the last movie from
sag that was unaffordable and the movie
hasn't even I don't know what I don't
want to complain about it but the movie
hasn't even you know broken even and
we're getting bills from sag for
residuals and the movie never came out
of theaters I'm not complaining right
now what I'm trying to say is I'd never
anticipated that so for my next film
I'll have to put away funds rather than
having to borrow
funds in order to pay for the my last
movie sag because the way the financials
work in independent filmmaking if you're
lucky enough to get a distributor and I
mean that honestly because there's so
much of a flood of independent
filmmaking now if you're an lucky enough
to get an independent distributor you
have one thing conquered but what you
don't have is the concept of how
Hollywood works you know first you're
the last person to get paid and then in
itself is troubling because I financed
the movie myself I can't even
conceptualize what it must feel like and
I do know somebody recently who made a
movie I believe Netflix wanted to buy it
for a substantial amount of money and
but not enough to break even and and the
filmmaker had no choice in the matter
because he was a hired hand even though
he directed the movie and produced it
all the money was borrowed and he really
you know had to acquiesce to the sale
and the I don't think the movies ever
broken even and he doesn't even talk to
the people that he borrowed the money
from and this is not a negative or a
positive it's just an observation of
just how you know perception reality I
had a guy yesterday tell me wow your
movie just came out yesterday it came
out and he goes are you gonna buy a new
house I'm going you read People magazine
yeah and I don't mean that as a joke
because it's the first thing you see in
the news
Star Wars made X amount of money no one
including myself has any context to
understanding what that means and the
outcome of it is is that you know I
think it's pretty critical to understand
that the business is changing my last
film in this film it's totally different
we didn't have a distributor when we did
the first movie we had a sales rep and
then he interns sold at the Fox he
interns sold it to Sony domestically and
it's not a question of good or bad it's
just a question of understanding and
this
around rather than sell it
internationally first we did what most
people do which I didn't know we sold
domestically first you know and now
we're selling Europe and all the other
territories so we're doing it probably a
much better way now than we did the
first time wanted to go back to what you
said about putting away reserves you
know I've heard this with people that
have business issues with payroll taxes
different things I don't think people
realize the the value of reserves or
saving yourself
well I'll kill two birds with one stone
here because I know you're gonna talk
about tax credits and I also talked
about the question you just asked me I
don't think you can ever really be too
prepared for how much money this stuff
all costs it is an extraordinary thing
that I made two movies now with a
non-union crew am i bragging about it
not at all but it made me afford to do
the movie I couldn't have done the movie
my first movie if it was a sanctioned
Union movie this is independent
filmmaking you know when you I just saw
a movie the other night that was all
shot on an iPhone of people traveling
from from Syria to to Berlin at a film
festival was brilliant all shot on an
iPhone and and I'm sure it's all his
family members so he doesn't have the
burden of the stuff I'm talking about I
actually make movies and I'm a signature
to sag
so I want the best talent I can get to
make these movies but with that comes a
lot of little surprises you know and
they're not surprises by deception
they're just ignorance and as a
filmmaker and a producer yeah I am and
as the world changes you know month
leaking in in this business I can tell
you right now most distributors that
distribute independent properties that
existed three years ago half them don't
exist anymore
because it's just not the business
models changed and when I made my last
movie DVDs were actually an interesting
proposition now it's a fragment so Hantz
and Lee is changing
you